foreign
good afternoon everybody
okay just
two quick things at the top we've seen
the breaking news reports of the tornado
damage in Selma First Our Hearts and
Thoughts go out to the summer community
and everyone impacted by the storm our
team here is monitoring and assessing
the situation and reaching out as
appropriate to local and state officials
to offer our support and before I start
and turn over to my colleague who is
going to be giving you all a preview of
the bilat that the president's going to
have with the Japanese prime minister
and also do a preview of next Tuesday
with the president's bilat with the
Prime Minister of Netherlands I just
want to
say a couple of things
and make sure that everyone saw this
it's a statement from Richard Sauber his
statement reads as the president said he
takes classified information and
materials seriously and as we have said
we have cooperated from the moment we
inform the archives that a small number
of documents were found and we will
continue to cooperate
we have cooperated closely with the
justice department throughout its review
and we will continue that cooperation
with the special counsel
we are confident that a thorough review
will show that these documents were
inadvertently misplaced and the
president and his lawyers acted promptly
upon discovering of this mistake with
that my colleague is here uh John Kirby
to talk through the bilat tomorrow and
also with Japan prime minister and also
the bilat with the Prime Minister of
Netherlands next Tuesday and then I'll
come back
afternoon everybody
I think tomorrow you know president
Brian's going to be welcoming the Prime
Minister kashidi of Japan here to the
White House he's looking for very much
forward to that two leaders have already
gotten to know each other quite well uh
during in-depth discussions uh over the
last year Cambodia at the East Asia
Summit and in Tokyo for their bilateral
meeting in the quad Summit in May of
2022 as well as do their work together
at the G7
since taking office President Biden has
invested in our alliances to better
equip us to collectively take on the
21st century challenges we face whether
that's the dprk's pursuit of weapons of
mass destructions uh and weapons of mass
destruction and ballistic missile and
their ballistic missile program China's
assertiveness and the indo-pacific
region and globally or of course
Russia's unprovoked war in Ukraine now
on each of these challenges and on many
more Japan has proven a steadfast Ally
ready to step up and do its part to
advance our shared National Security
interests and values I'm just going to
be set a little bit of the backdrop here
for this particular visit last month
prime minister kashida released Japan's
New National Security strategy and
committed to boosting Japan's defense
spending to two percent of their GDP and
that includes investments in new defense
capabilities and that's a historic
commitment by Japan
prime minister kashida will arrive in
Washington after a set of extensive
actually has arrived after a set of
extensive discussions with European
Partners from Italy to the UK to France
of course to Canada uh and he and
President Biden are going to have the
opportunity to debrief on those
discussions as well and then of course
yesterday you saw the two foreign
ministers and the two defense Ministers
of our countries get together and
announce some significant new uh
improvements to the alliance upgrades in
fact to U.S force posture in Japan which
can now include the stationing of a
marine littoral regiment in Okinawa as
well as advanced capabilities from
intelligence collection analyst analysis
to anti-ship capabilities but we
modernize the alliance by announcing
that attacks to from and within space
could lead to the invocation of Article
5 of the U.S Japan security treaty
expanding bilateral exercises between
our two countries and training which
includes uh in the Japan's in Japan's
Southwest Islands and of course
deepening cooperation in the region to
include trilateral training and
exercises with Australia and increasing
cooperation with the Republican Republic
of Korea on ballistic missile defense
anti-submarine Warfare Maritime security
all these moves are not only going to
strengthen our combined ability to
defend Japan
but also will allow the United States
and Japan together to provide for the
peace and Security in the indo-pacific
region and bolster deterrence uh in the
region and globally now I do think that
tomorrow will also give President Biden
an opportunity to discuss with prime
minister kashida progress that we're
going to be able to make together in
this coming year on a range of National
Security and economic issues Japan I
think you know holds the G7 presidency
they've just taken a seat on the U.N
security Council and while we're going
to be hosting the Apec this year as well
as seeking to make Swift progress on the
indo-pacific economic framework there's
a lot of overlap there and we're looking
forward to that we'll discuss how we're
going to align these agendas uh going
forward so tomorrow's program we expect
it's going to be a full one but from our
perspective the message is absolutely
clear Japan is stepping up and doing
doing so in lockstep with the United
States our investment in our alliances
is paying huge dividends and we look
forward to celebrating that tomorrow
speaking of alliances and Partnerships
I'm also pleased to announce that next
week President Biden will welcome prime
minister Mark Ruta of the Netherlands to
the White House on Tuesday the 17th to
further deepen the historic ties between
our two Nations as strong NATO allies
and Global Partners these two leaders
are going to reaffirm our shared efforts
to strengthen transatlantic security and
economic Prosperity they'll discuss our
steadfast support of Ukraine and the
Netherlands has been a very key
supporter of security assistance in
Ukraine in fact they've already provided
a a billion dollars of that and are
committing sorry almost 3 billion
committed and committing almost a
billion more going forward they're going
to be able to discuss all that
cooperation going forward on critical
Technologies and a shared vision for a
swift end to this to this war in Ukraine
they also plan to talk about a range of
issues that are essential to
strengthening democracy whether that's
respect for human rights rules-based
International order around the world and
including uh as co-hosts of the upcoming
second Summit for democracy so a big
week next week too with a very key Ally
and partner we're looking forward to
that
John I understand that the leaders will
be focused on deterring uh the threat
from China as well as other adversaries
including Russia nuclear-powered
adversaries North Korea Russia China but
what would the leaders be thinking about
in terms of this latest reaction this
latest announcement from South Korea
saying that they're open to acquiring
nuclear weapons will uh President Biden
and prime minister kishida be focused on
this and does the administration believe
that a nuclear South Korea contradicts
U.S policy of denuclearization in the
entire Peninsula the United States
remains committed President Biden
remains committed to the complete
denuclearization of the peninsula and uh
and that hasn't changed
the
Republic of Korea has made clear that
they are not seeking nuclear weapons but
what we are going to see jointly
together with them uh are improvements
uh in extended deterrence capabilities
so we're going to move forward on that
while we have you here Ukraine has
confirmed that they will be receiving
tanks from the UK as well as Poland
and during president's Olympic's visit I
think President Biden made it clear that
the reason that the U.S is not providing
all the weapons that Ukraine is asking
including these kinds of you know tanks
is to ensure that the US is avoiding an
escalation to the war and ensuring NATO
Unity does the present believe that UK
and Poland's decision to provide thanks
to Ukraine will work against those goals
the president fully supports those
decisions and those are sovereign
decisions that those Nations make about
this kind of security assistance they
provide that's been the case throughout
this entire length of the war we respect
that sovereignty and we certainly are
grateful for all the additional security
assistance that nations are providing I
talked about the Netherlands they've
provided uh air defense capabilities as
well as howitzers
um so we're grateful for that and and
but these are decisions that they have
to make the president believes and these
announcements I think reinforce this
belief that there is terrific solidarity
by the International Community behind
Ukraine and finding ways to support
Ukraine just next week uh secretary of
defense will be hosting yet another
contact group meeting over in Europe to
contribute or find ways to contribute
more security assistance from more
Partners those have been very very
successful so the president believes
that these that all these decisions are
actually mutually reinforcing of a
larger issue here and that is solid
International Community Support behind
Ukraine
there's going to be any more
announcement outside of the defense
aspects of this visit I'm not going to
get ahead of uh the meeting that hasn't
happened yet I'll let the president
summarize it we'll have we'll have a
readout afterward thank you I'm not a
Japan question since we have you here
John
um an organization called a hostage Aid
worldwide has sent a letter to the
president asking for a meeting with him
regarding the hostages that have been
held who are dual National who've been
held all over the world but particularly
in Iran until now they have not got an
answer do you know why the White House
is not giving them the attention they've
been given to other hostages we take
each case uh uh seriously and we take
each case individually and just to be
clear dual National citizenship has
nothing to do with it if you have a blue
passport if you're if you're an American
citizen whether you're a citizen of
another Nation or not doesn't matter
that means you're going to be treated
the same all Americans are treated the
same regardless of whether they have the
citizenship in another Nation Paul
whalen's a great example of that so we
worked each case individually we work
each click case seriously and we try to
keep the families as informed as
possible I I won't speak to specific
meetings that that have or have or have
not occurred uh when we get requests for
meetings we take those seriously too and
do the best we can to accommodate and
certainly uh we want to make sure that
um
that in our Communications with family
members that we are not doing or saying
anything that actually makes it harder
for us to establish a release mechanism
for them and and you have to be mindful
of that when you're in the public
talking about these cases that you
you've got to be careful that you're not
putting anything out there in the public
space that could make it harder so each
one is reviewed individually and
sincerely and if and if a meeting can be
done and should be done then you know
then then we certainly will work to
accommodate that follow up with this
letter I'm sorry
we're certain we're familiar with the
letter I don't have a response to the
letter for you I wouldn't do that from
the podium I will certainly uh respond
appropriately
conus on the agenda for tomorrow John I
won't get ahead of the president's uh uh
discussion with prime minister kashida
James uh we're certainly the president
is aware of the Lieutenant's
circumstances in Japan
um uh as his uh leadership across the
military in the defense department
um but uh but I'm not gonna I won't
preview or get ahead of the president's
specific agenda thank you so much
he looks your reaction the president's
reaction to reports that Russia is
building up in forces in the East what's
the significance of that and where do
things stand in terms of any potential
effort to try to get the two sides to
sit down at the table
inside Ukraine inside Ukraine yes and I
am we've obviously been watching very
closely uh military operations
particularly in the eastern Ukraine the
donbass area and as I've said even from
from here in the briefing room the the
violence the fighting in areas around
back mood and now this town called
solidar has been uh has has been
significant and severe and the fighting
has been sharp between both sides we've
talked about in back move specifically
this is largely private military
contractors it's Mr pagosian largely in
the Wagner group that have been involved
in much of the ground fighting there but
it has been vicious and that's why uh
get going into the winter knowing that
the fighting isn't slowing down there
that that we have been so focused on
providing additional security assistance
to Ukraine just last week Kareem
announced for you know nearly three
billion dollars worth of of systems and
there will be more coming Kristin I
can't speak to Russian intent here or
specific uh unit movements or or what
their goals are I wouldn't I wouldn't
presume to to speak for the Russian
defense Ministry I would just tell you
that as they continue to literally throw
bodies at the fighting in bathroom
because they have lost an extraordinary
amount of largely convicts in this
fighting as they continue to do that
they need to know and understand that
the United States as well as our allies
and partners are going to continue to
make sure that ukr Ukraine can defend
itself in that area and do so
effectively and I mean I don't mean to
belabor this but look at the area right
this is the donbass area we've talked
about this it's a lot like Kansas it's
Farmland it's open ground and so we want
to make sure that we are providing the
kinds of capabilities to Ukraine to be
able to succeed in that environment
that's why Bradley Fighting Vehicles
were part of the package that Korean
announced that's why the Pentagon will
very soon be DOD and and our allies will
be starting some combined arms maneuver
training outside of Ukraine for up to
Battalion level units of the Ukrainian
Armed Forces to help them in this fight
can I just try one more we're going to
direct 99 of our questions about the
class it would be okay with me if it was
100 I do have one for you has there been
an assessment about any potential
National Security risk of having
classified
in the president's private Think Tank
here in Washington and his home in
Delaware that would be a question for
the justice department because they are
conducting they're conducting a review
now you saw that they've announced a
special counsel that issue would be for
them to speak to we speak broadly to the
National Security concerns about having
classified documents in private spaces
the president has spoken to uh to how
seriously he takes uh the handling of
classified documents and
um
he as somebody who's aware of the
process myself
did exactly the right thing which is to
have them immediately turned over and
that's that's where this appropriately
lies and again the justice department
would be would be the place to go to
answer your question
yes I have one question on Japan then
maybe one on Ukraine on Japan
um
are you are they going to be discussing
the semiconductor uh exports to China
and efforts to restrict those uh exports
is that going to be a topic and
is it do you see this as very important
to have a country like Japan join those
efforts to have some sort of chips
control if not a ban but to to have
efforts in that area to control again I
want to be careful not to get ahead of
President Biden uh I I think as I
alluded to it's going to be a very full
and robust agenda but I think it's safe
to say that when it comes to issues he
discusses routinely with his
counterparts bilaterally and then
multilateral settings Supply chains
resilient Supply chains to include uh
with respect to high technology is
always a a part of the discussion but I
won't again get ahead of of what they're
going to say and on the Ukraine I know
you've said many times you don't want to
talk about the intent of the Russians
but what do you mean it's not that I
don't want to I can't I mean I
uh the the new assignment if you could
call it a Valerie garasimo and what does
that say maybe about the Russian
strategy as he's been named the new man
in charge of the war efforts yeah
they've gone through quite a few
leadership changes haven't they now in
10 and a half months
um and uh again I think Kareem said this
very well yesterday we'll let the
Kremlin speak to their decision making
here
um but uh but they've gone through a lot
of leadership changes uh clearly in an
effort
almost from very early on in an effort
to overcome the sorts of difficulties
they've had in this world difficulties
which remain whether that's Logistics
and sustainment uh uh ISR intelligence
surveillance reconnaissance the ability
to gather information to communicate
command and control between units
certainly unit morale and cohesion and
without a doubt I mean just look at
what's been going on in the last couple
of weeks Battlefield performance so
interesting that they have now gone back
to grazimov who was in charge at the
very beginning who is essentially the
chief of their Army staff not an
operational Commander it's an
interesting selection I think you know
they they should speak to that but I
think it's indicative and shows the
degree to which the Russians continue to
struggle to get it right in terms of
just leadership command and control
problems yeah thank you so much I had a
question like tensions are arising again
between Sweden and turkey how confident
are you does that these two countries
can resolve these tensions and how
confident are you that swim would be
able to join NATO soon and I would have
a problem we firmly support their
Ascension I think you know that
President Biden's made that very very
clear
um and uh and uh so too does the the
vast majority of of NATO Nations
um I certainly let those two Nations
speak for themselves in terms of the
discussions that they're having you saw
yesterday Swedish officials said
publicly that they believe that that
these discussions are actually on a
positive track and we certainly hope
that's the case on the classified
documents have there been you know any
other countries in touch with the
administration expressing some kind of
concerns about how secure classified
documents are and how like confidential
information about those countries could
have circulated I'm not aware of any
such discussions or concerns
uh thank you um uh the family and uh
supporters of a Russian dissident Alexey
navalny are increasingly concerned about
his health in fact even Russian doctors
are openly putting their name to a
letter yeah is there anything you can do
to let the Karla know that we share the
concerns and it continued
believe they should be immediately
released obviously and short of that to
make to insist that he gets proper
Medical Care uh so we've seen those
concerns and share those concerns uh and
uh uh we'll continue to make plain uh
those concerns to Russian authorities
sir the United States concerned that uh
solidar has fallen to the Russians or is
could be falling to the Russians can't
confirm the reports that it's Fallen I
mean I've seen the Russian proclamations
about this uh the ukrainians tell a
different story we're not on the ground
so I'm not we're not in a position to
confirm it
um it's a small village in the donbass
uh uh we believe that the Russian
interest in it um is sort of two-fold
one because they see it's securing it as
key to their ability to hold and secure
and then to hold Bak moot there's also
salt mines there so we also think that
there's a bit of an economic incentive
particularly by Mr percosian uh to take
possessions
what would that say about Russia
advances in that area I think yeah great
question I think look we got to take a
little we got to keep this in
perspective
um
we don't know how it's going to go so
I'm not going to predict failure or
success here
but even if uh both Bak mood and
soledadar fall to the Russians it's not
going to make a uh it's not going to
have a strategic impact
on the war itself and it certainly isn't
going to stop the ukrainians or or slow
them down in terms of their uh their
efforts to regain their territory and I
would remind I mean I know we're all
focused on those two towns right now but
just again take a couple of steps back
and if you look at what's been happening
over the last 10 and a half months
particularly in the Dom boss towns and
Villages have swapped hands quite
frequently so uh my last
comment would be don't count the
ukrainians out
thank you I would like to follow up on
Patsy's question on the tanks for
Ukraine Poland says that it will deliver
the tanks only as a part as a of a
larger International Coalition
and it's an encouraging other countries
to join so I'm wondering if President
Biden is considering joining the
scholation by sending U.S Abrams tanks
and if he is encouraging other countries
including Germany to do the same
I won't get ahead of decisions on
security assistance that haven't been
made yet
um
we have been
I think very effective at providing
security assistance that evolves with
the way the war has evolved
um and you know now you know two weeks
ago we were talking about Patriots and
air defense and today you know we're
talking about armored vehicles and and
and tanks
um so I won't get ahead of the
president's decisions he's going to make
as I said to Patsy we're grateful for
the support that other nations are are
are providing they each do it in their
own way
in a size scale and scope and a pace
that they're comfortable with these are
sovereign decisions and we respect that
the president zielinski has said he's
interested in tanks and now you have
some countries that are showing a
willingness to provide tanks that's all
to The Good the United States will
continue to provide our security
assistance in in the same way we have
for the last 10 and a half months look
working in lockstep with the ukrainians
and making sure that that we're meeting
their needs as best we can and if we
can't that we're working with allies and
partners to do the same and and
and again I uh you asked about this
Coalition or Alliance again we believe
that there has been an incredible
framework established already
internationally to provide
uh assistant security assistant
specifically to Ukraine and that's
through this Ukraine defense contact
group there's another meeting next week
we're very excited about that and
looking forward to it because the
President says that the war is in a
critical point
if the war is at a critical point why
wait it takes time to train ukrainians
to operate those things
nobody's waiting I mean almost every two
weeks like clockwork we're getting up
here and talking to you about uh
billions of dollars of more assistance
that are going to Ukraine United States
is the leader of the world I mean we've
almost 25 billion dollars since the
start of this war No Other Nation comes
close to providing the kind of security
assistance that we have it's not about
waiting it's about working in lockstep
with ukrainians making sure that we
understand their needs and capabilities
and delivering those capabilities the
best way that we can now and when I say
we I don't just mean the U.S I mean the
big we and sometimes those assets are
not going to come from the United States
sometimes they're going to come from
other nations and maybe that's better
for the ukrainians either because they
can get there faster or because it's uh
it's a capability that they're more
comfortable using and won't need quite
as much training and operation and
maintenance on it there's lots of
reasons like lots of things that go into
these decisions yeah
oh I was in fact going to ask not that
we don't always appreciate uh your
appearance in the briefing room but if
we could maybe better today
it's fine it's fine with me I I will
depart all right thanks everybody
oh my goodness
wow Justin Justin did not hold back at
all
um and I think you did that on the plane
last week too I remember I'm keeping
track I'm keeping track um
all right Chris it's yours uh so a few
questions about the classified documents
uh first off is the president willing to
be interviewed by federal investigators
about his handling of classified doctor
so first let me just say I'm just not
going to get into hypotheticals this is
something for the Department
it's an ongoing review right you're
asking me about something in the future
and I am telling you that I'm not going
to get ahead of what the Department of
Justice is going to decide look I want
to reiterate uh what you heard from the
president today it is important for the
American people to know this uh is that
the president has said he takes
classified documents and information
very seriously this is something as you
all know that he uh that he will not shy
away from saying and has continued to
say this this week and again he was
surprised that these uh Records have
been found he does not know what's in
them and his team once they identified
that these documents were were there
they immediately reached out to to The
Archives of the Department of Justice
and did the rightfully so did the right
thing by turning that over and they have
been cooperating very closely with the
Department of Justice you actually heard
A.G attorney general Garland say today
that they heard from his team really
shortly after the discovery and so uh
you know I just want to make sure that
this is understood that he takes this
very seriously
seriously uh this is the kind of thing
caused government employees who lose the
security clearance this is a serious
matter as the weather said uh was the
president's sloppy is handling
classified material after our multiple
locations where classified documents are
being found look I said this in my I
said that in the statement it's in the
statement of uh from his lawyer Richard
Sauber and at the end he said we are
confident that they are a thorough
review will show that these documents
were inadvertently misplaced and the
president and his lawyers acted promptly
upon discovery of this mistake I'm going
to leave it there that's what his lawyer
said but again this is something that
the president it takes very seriously
and we have been coordinating they have
been coordinating his lawyers I've been
coordinating very closely with the
Department of Justice the last thing is
initial statement providers coming on
Monday the president addressed us on
Tuesday Mexico City all the
conversations about the documents in the
office however according to attorney
general doctors were founded December
20th in his garage of Wilmington why was
that not immediately addressed is the
weather's being transparent about that
if that was already known and not
discussed up front so just to you said
transparent I want to say that we have
been transparent here that is why the
minute that his lawyers found those
documents they reported it they reached
out to the archives and the Department
of Justice and they did that voluntarily
and they were not compelled to do it
they did it voluntarily now I want to
step back a little bit as you're asking
me about the timeline look the lawyer
said we have been working closely with
the Department of Justice and
coordinating a search that was still
ongoing to ensure any additional
documents were in the proper possession
of the government after that search
uh after the search concluded last night
we released a statement disclosing the
facts from that search as you all know
this morning this is all part of the
justice department process and you heard
the Attorney General speak to this today
so we are being very careful to be fully
Cooperative with the Department of
Justice and providing details as
appropriate as part of that process so
why did you fully describe the documents
when we were personally asked this week
because and I and I actually answered
that question I said because there was a
process happening that was currently
ongoing and uh and I'll refer you back
to my comments that I made just
yesterday go ahead Mary couple things I
want to clarify just to make sure that
our recording is as accurate as possible
you know the the special counsels the
White House council's statement this
morning said that documents were found
in the president's Wilmington residents
garage and in an adjacent room but when
the president mentioned this himself in
person earlier he said they were found
in storage areas and in his personal
Library so can you just clear this up
which room where were the documents
actually found in his residence okay so
let me just step back because I know all
of you will have a lot of questions so
I'll lay this out very clearly and
precisely I don't want clearly we want
to make sure no one is confused as you
just said Mary as soon as the
president's lawyers found these
documents they immediately contacted
archives and Department of Justice as
I've said many times already to ensure
that they were handled properly the
president has said this we are being
fully Cooperative with the Department of
Justice throughout this process as part
of the president's lawyers look through
the places where documents could have
been stored and the council's office
released as you said a statement
explaining that so I would refer you
back to the statement I don't have
anything more to say but that search was
completed last night and now this is in
the hands of the justice department so
look I want to be very prudent here as I
said yesterday as you all have reported
over and over again uh so about any
questions about this any specifics
there's a review going on and I would
refer to Department of Justice or my
colleagues in the council's office but
again I'm just not going to go beyond
what the president said we just laid out
where we just laid out the process that
was taken it's not what you're saying we
should go off of the council statement
saying it was found in the garage in an
adjacent room I'm just saying no I'm
just saying I'm not going to go beyond
what the Pres the president said I'm not
gonna I I completely I Mary I completely
understand I just want to be very
careful because there is an ongoing
investigation I want to be prudent here
and make sure if you have any additional
questions about where where things were
found again I refer you to the statement
I'm not going to go beyond what the
president said and one of their point of
clarification if the president said
Tuesday he was surprised to learn about
the documents at the Penn Biden Center
that he didn't know what was in these
documents he didn't sort of repeat that
this morning about the documents found
at his residence so was he also
surprised to learn that there were
classified documents at his residence
and does he know any information about
it he again he was surprised that the uh
that the documents uh were there and
that is that is also in line with uh
what we what we shared this morning and
again he takes this very seriously when
it comes to classified information when
it comes to uh um uh classified
documents and again it still stays the
same he was surprised that the records
were found he does not know what's in
them that has not changed and again his
team when they identified that they were
uh that they um that they were there
they immediately reached out to the
archives reached out to doj just as they
did last night and and as we have pretty
much laid out uh previously and one more
just because as much has been made of
the differences here between what you
all have handled these documents and the
way that the former president handled
documents that were taken from the White
House when the FBI went the fbm sorry
Garland said when the FBI went to the
location being the president's residence
uh and secured these documents did the
FBI just retrieve documents or was there
a search of the residents again I'm just
not going to go into this particulars or
the specifics of what the Department of
Justice did I can speak to what we have
done uh and what is already out there we
laid out a statement pretty extensively
on Monday we've been laid out a
statement this morning on what was found
last night I'm just not going to go
beyond I would refer you to Department
of of Justice to give you the specifics
on that as you know there's an ongoing
process there's a review currently
occurring
can you shed any light on how the
documents got to these places and why
again there's an ongoing process it's
being reviewed I don't have any uh don't
have more to share I'm going to let the
Department of Justice uh answer any
questions as they're looking at this
there's the White House I think that the
appointment of a special prosecutor was
born I'm not going to get into the
decisions that were that was made by the
Attorney General I will say this and
you've heard me say this many times
before this is the president that
believes in the independence of the
justice department this is something
that he has been saying since the
campaign and you've heard me say this
over and over and restoring that
Independence so look we have been very
very careful here not to appear from the
White House to influence their decision
making on on on on
any number of issues as you've heard me
say over and over again I've said this
many times I'm sure someone has counted
the amount of times that I've said that
the Department of Justice is independent
and we respect their independence I am
certainly not going to comment on uh or
give my opinion uh or we are are we
going to give our opinion on what the
Attorney General laid out today what
Broadway does the White House make of
comparisons between president
guidance handling of documents and
former president Trump's family I'm not
going to get into politics from here
what I can say is what I've laid out
which is the president takes this very
seriously he does he said this twice and
he did not know that the records were
there when they were found he does not
know what's in them and what he did and
what his team did is the minute that
they realized that the documents were
there they reached out to the archives
they reach out to Department of Justice
and I'll just leave it I'll leave it
I'll leave it there and I'll leave you
all to uh to pontificate and do your
punditry I will not do that from here go
ahead thanks uh in the statement from
the social Council that the second set
of documents that the lawyers have
completed the ongoing review by the
president's legal team last night does
that mean there are no other locations
where documents could be stored there's
no other search underway at this moment
in time for documentary vice president
so as uh as I'm just gonna again that
that statement pretty much lays that
lays it out that they
um they have
as part as the lawyers they look through
the places where documents could have
been stored and the council's office
released a statement on that now it is
in the hands of the special counsel so
we should assume it you should assume
that it's been completed yes okay and I
just want to discourse something that
Chris was asking about the review was
underway when you guys gave a detailed
statement about the first set of
documents the review was underway when
the president spoke about the first set
of documents you're now saying that you
didn't talk about the second set of
documents discovered almost a month
prior because a review was underway like
I don't understand it doesn't make any
sense he was underway the entire time
the only difference was that reporters
had information on the first set of
documents and therefore you chose to
exclude the second set of documents
until reporters got information on the
second set of God well let me unconfuse
you uh for a second Phil look we are
trying to do this by the book and I said
yesterday this was under review by the
Department of Justice and the process is
as such when the print when the
president's lawyers realized that the
documents existed that they were there
they reached out to the archives they
reached out to the Department of Justice
rightfully so may I add that is what
you're supposed to do as lawyers that's
what they did and they have fully been
cooperating uh with um with the
Department of Justice and again I said
this earlier in answering a question you
heard from the attorney general he said
shortly after the documents were
discovered uh they they that we did
Outreach the president's lawyers did
Outreach uh to uh to the Department of
Justice and archives questioning that
that's not what we're asking about we're
asking about I'm telling you that
there's a process I just laid out what
the processes and I'm telling you that
we were trying to do this by the book
and it it was on ongoing process I'm not
going to get beyond that but that is how
this works
how can you say this was transparent
when you've set all this information for
more than two months
thank you green um thank
you
permission and I appreciate and
understand why the Press office
basically say so much so help us
understand it who are the president's
personal counsel that the Attorney
General will referred to today uh I have
to get I was asked that question earlier
let me get back to you I actually don't
have that answer I think I know who it
is but I want to make a 100 career Bob
Bauer is one potentially Dana Remus
James Garland Robert Lane uh
look again I I don't want to I want to
say the right thing from here so I we
would uh have to I would have talked to
the White House counsel or you would
have to reach out to the White House
Council to talk about who who is his
personal lawyers
the first set of documents were found in
November at the Penn binding Center here
in Washington
why did it take until yesterday
until this morning apparently for
whoever it was
that that final document was found was
that because the refresh reports earlier
this week again their Hope was that
nobody would find out again was it
because there is a process an ongoing
process that is occurring we did this by
the book and what I mean by that is the
moment that the lawyers discovered that
the papers were there or the documents
were there they reached out to the
archives they reach out to Department of
Justice and they immediately rightfully
so
reached out to them to let them know
what what they had discovered and that
is the process uh that is what we that
that is what his lawyers did uh and uh
again it's an ongoing process as you
stated in your question I am Limited in
what I can say it is now in the hands of
the Department of Justice they are
reviewing this as you know the special
counsel was announced by the attorney
general and so I will uh leave it there
what was the president trying to say
when he referenced his Corvette earlier
today because it sounded like he was
implying that because his garage is a
safe place for his car the documents
were saved
and therefore it was if it was safe for
the car it was safe for the documents is
that what he meant look I I'm going to
just leave his statement as is uh I
think you your colleagues was having a
back and forth with the president uh you
can read the transcript of what was
asked of him and why he responded that
way I'm just not going to get into
specifics well you talked about we are
being transparent
and what is the definition of
transparent in this case is it the
lawyers being transparent legally for
the archives and the justice department
or is it the White House with large
being transparent with the general
public so number one
and I've said this multiple times
already we take this very seriously the
president takes this very seriously he
was not aware that the records were
there he does not know what what is in
the documents again classified
information uh classified documents he
takes very seriously when they were
discovered
and this is the right thing to do right
his lawyers reached out immediately to
the archivist they reached out to
Department of Justice to let them know
that the the papers or the documents
assistant or the justice department
because the Attorney General this
morning said that the attorneys reached
out to the archives it was only later in
December when the second batch was
apparently
I will leave it I will leave it to what
the Department of Justice is laying out
what we are saying that we reached out
to the archivist we reached out to
Department of Justice that is what is
the right thing to do in this case and
not and and and so I can finish here
um what has been transparent in this as
well is that the White House Council has
let has laid out in detail on Monday to
all of you everything Karina and you
know that first of all I can't talk
about this right because it is the
Department of Justice is reviewing it
there is a review happening Ed right you
know this we just heard from the
attorney general there is a review I am
Limited in what I can say to this
come here I think you should I think you
should reach out uh to the White House
counselor
okay okay I am saying to you that we
have put out lengthy statements and you
can reach out to them as you all have
been doing and I will leave it there go
ahead go ahead why not have them come
and answer yes I they have been they
have been talking to you all pretty
regularly the last couple of days uh we
have put out they have put out uh
lengthy statements on this I just read
out uh what Richard Sarver had to say
and I would refer you to the White House
Council I am Limited in what I can say
because because the Department of
Justice we see them as being independent
when it comes to these types of issues
and so I I'm not going to go beyond what
the president said and I'm not going to
go beyond what the lawyers say I have to
go around you've asked me about you've
asked me
there's going to limit and transparency
public not legal transparency and what
can be shared and said by this way I
disagree there has I disagree and there
has not been a limit of transparency
that is that is that is there has not
been a limit of transparency that I will
I will disagree with you on that Justin
Justin thanks Karen uh I I did want to
kind of follow up on what Ed and Phil
were asking which is putting aside the
question of whether the president's
lawyer is acted properly and handing the
documents over there's this lingering
question of why there wasn't an
acknowledgment of the second set of
documents earlier this week and you said
that you're working through a process
and going by the book and I'm what I'm
curious is if you're trying to
sort of hint at the idea that the
justice department asked you not to
reveal the second set of documents or
you were told in some way not to
disclose anything that had not been made
public I I would not jump to those two
conclusions that is not what I'm stating
I am genuinely saying to you there is an
ongoing process that we are going to
follow and I am Limited in what I can
say from here that is why my White House
Council colleagues are the we refer to
them these past couple of days now this
is in the hands of Department of Justice
as we as as you all heard from the
attorney general himself thank you
I guess I remain confused if the justice
department didn't ask you not to
disclose these documents why on Monday
as this news was coming out Tuesday as
the president was talking about it you
didn't say here's everything we know at
this point
you know the
the first that was found at the confine
Center the second set was founded his
office were searching to make sure that
there's nothing else because there's an
ongoing process and you heard directly
from from the attorney general today and
that is the process that is how this is
going to go it is not going to come from
here from me at this Podium it is going
to come from the Department of Justice
and that is just the process that's
happening currently I feel slightly bad
about chasing Kirby from the room so I'm
going to ask you one thing not about the
special counsel which is what no now you
can't you can't now ask a question that
you could have asked the Kirby well it
wasn't for Kirby if it was for you okay
you got a question yesterday actually
about moderna raising the prices of the
cover vaccine and so that you take the
question I was wondering and I did I
actually did and Michael is not here I
was going to provide this information uh
to him today so I don't want first I
don't want anybody to be confused here
as you know this is incredibly important
so you can go to 90 000 locations and
get a moderner or any covid-19 shot for
free that is currently what folks can do
and they are our best protection against
the xbb 1.5 right now so please if you
haven't please go get your shot as
you've heard from me as you've heard
from our uh covid-19 Team here has been
very clear on why this is important and
why folks should get their shots what
when as it relates to the question what
Senator Sanders is talking about is
future shots and the process of moving
forward moving toward a commercial
market for covet shots so we share this
concern that those shots should be
affordable that is something that we TR
we share the concern with Senator
Sanders the price hike here is hard to
to understand or to justify again we uh
we are we do have those concerns as well
and we believe that shot should be
affordable yeah a couple of basic
geography questions you may not be able
to answer but is the library a room
adjacent to the garage again I I don't
have any any of this information that I
can provide I would this is under review
I would
um I I would uh refer you to Department
of Justice I'm just not going to go into
specifics here not something that I can
do from here and is the president's
Corvette stored in the garage where the
documents were found just for perfect
purposes well I will basically repeat
what the president said his Corvette is
in the garage I'm not going to go beyond
what the president said okay and on the
transparency issue
um
would you
um admit that earlier this week the
White House shared incomplete
information uh I think that when we all
heard Merrick Garland say that these
documents that the residents were found
on December 20th that they were notified
that was pretty surprising to all of us
based on the statements that you and the
president and the council's office had
made well as I just said that as you saw
in our statement the documents uh that
were found last night wait they
completed uh the uh the search with
documents being found last night and
then this morning we put out uh we put
out you heard from the White House
Council uh you we put out the
information on uh specifically what was
found but just one document was found
last night last night the search was
continuing it was ongoing the process as
I've been saying was ongoing and the the
search is clearly complete and therefore
we share the information with all of you
again this is an ongoing process I would
refer you to the Department of Justice
on any other specifics or particulars uh
even on timeline uh any other questions
that you have
all right
oh I'm gonna come back go ahead
to
um a couple questions but is the
president confident you said that the
search has been completed but is the
president confident that there are no
additional documents with classified
markings that remain in any other
additional locations look uh I can just
refer you to what his team said the
search is complete he is confident in
this process and I will leave it there
and and they've been cooperating very
closely with the Department of Justice
and we've gotten a statement that the
White House did not get advanced notice
that Garland was pointing that is
correct when did the president learn how
did he learn uh was it from the press
conference did he get a heads up before
that we learned from the press
conference the president the president
we we were not giving a heads up and we
learned from the press conference he was
in a funeral at the time when did
somebody tell
him look he was at a funeral to your
point maybe one of his uh one of his
senior advisors may have told him I
actually don't know specifically when he
knew but what I can say to you he was we
were not giving a heads up that I can
confirm as you all know already and have
you had a chance to talk to him since
then I have not had a chance to talk to
the president about this or his reaction
um does the White House feel like House
Republicans have a right to conduct an
investigation on documents issue they've
of course start started sending requests
and saying they're going to look into
this
um does that
fall in the realm of sort of legitimate
requests from from House Republicans
look I'm not going to speak to the what
the House Republicans decide to do what
I can speak to is that we are the
president's lawyers is is uh complying
and they they are working on this uh
with the Department of Justice as they
have been again this is something that
the president takes very seriously when
it comes to classified information when
it comes to classified documents I'm
just not going to go into what what the
Republicans uh on the house do or don't
do sorry just separate from from this I
was wondering if the White House had any
thought on the Senate primary in
California that's shaping up so as you
know uh the president
sees Senator Feinstein as a long time
friend and also a colleague who he
deeply respects and has collaborated on
historic pieces of legislations over the
years and such as the last Federal ban
on assault assault assault weapons so he
respects The Talented officials in
California who are expressing interest
in running for her seat and we are
prohibited from here as you know about
talking about campaigns or elections not
something that I can do from from the
podium so it would be inappropriate for
me to weigh in with more specifics on
any forthcoming Senate race including
including the one in California but
clearly he sees her as a longtime friend
and colleague
yeah the president uh when he was in
Mexico City and asked about the
classified documents that were found in
in the private Office of the Penn Biden
Center said that he didn't know what the
documents contained or what was in them
is that the case also with the documents
found at his Wilmington residence that
he didn't know he doesn't know what
those documents involved yeah I already
answered the question and he does not
know he's not aware of that the doctor
the records version
I'll come over sorry could you just
clarify a little bit more about when you
say that we informed the archives meet
at the Department of Justice immediately
since this happens in various points in
time what exactly was said at which
juncture because it seems to be there's
some conflict there in some but look
again I will refer you to the Department
of Justice what I can tell you is that
his lawyers uh reached out to the
archivist to the Department of Justice
which is what you're supposed to do
which is the right thing to do I'm not
going to get into specifics of time of
who who they reached out to first I
would refer you to the White House
Council to get more specifics it is an
ongoing process and I would again refer
to either the White House Council the
Department of Justice for that for that
specific question go ahead Kristin just
a couple of outstanding clarifications
before I get to questions
um salver said there were documents in
the garage and one document in an
adjacent room Merrick Garland said the
doj was informed of one additional
document this morning is that the same
document the additional document in the
document founded so let me just say
there during the review and this is so
that folks know the lawyers discovered
among personal and political papers a
small number of additional Obama Biden
Administration records with classified
markings all but one of these documents
were found in storage space and the
president's Wilmington residence
garage one document consisting of one
page was discovered among stored
materials in a adjacent room no
documents were found in the Rehoboth
Beach House look I just want to
underscore that this is something again
that that the president takes very
seriously it underscores how we executed
the search with the doj to uh to make to
make sure that they continued
cooperating fully with the review and I
think that is what we are trying to be
to be very clear about is that we have
been the the president's lawyers has
been cooperating fully fully I'm I'm not
going to get into the specifics as to
you have the statement I would refer you
to the president's lawyer or anything
else uh specifically on this or the
Department of Justice because they are
actually reviewing this currently to go
back to something we were trying to pin
down yesterday can you can you today
when did the president find out
initially about that first batch of
documents and then the second batch our
reporting says he was told on November
2nd is that true so what I can say to
you uh is that the president uh has been
kept uh in has been kept informed by his
Council throughout this process I found
it don't don't have a specific date but
I can tell you that the president was
kept uh informed throughout don't have a
timeline to share for you right now
again this is under ongoing review and
so want to be careful and prudent on
what I share here at the podium when the
search started and why they were
searching in the first place was the
president concerned that there may be
classified documents did someone tip
them off what sparked this again I'm
just not going to go into details from
here I'm not going to go into specifics
from here this is an undergoing this
review is continuing is ongoing I would
refer you to Department of Justice you
have said repeatedly the president has
said he takes classified documents very
seriously if that's the case why were
these if I documents being stored in his
garage
look again and not just me he has said
this you have heard the president say
this twice already and he's said this
before classified documents and
information he takes that very seriously
and you see garage is an appropriate
place to store I'm I'm not going to go
into uh into into what he thinks or how
he feels about what is currently
happening what I can say for sure when
it comes to this specific issue about
classified documents about classified
information he takes that very seriously
he did not know right he did not know
the records were there he was surprised
that the records were there so let's be
very clear that is something that the
president shared with all of you on the
world stage and also recently today uh
and uh and so what he what occurred was
as I've said multiple times before is
when his team identified that these
records uh existed they did they they
handed them over to the archivist and
also the department
that the fact that the White House did
not reveal this to the public despite
the fact that you've known about it for
months undercuts the president's promise
of being transparent with the American
but we but here's the thing they were
transparent there was there there was
transparency in doing what you're
supposed to do when these when these
items were discovered not with the
American people look we I am here
standing in front of you answering these
questions right the president took two
questions this week on this you've heard
wait let me just answer you've heard
from the White House counsel who put out
multiple statements on this and so again
this is an ongoing process we want to
respect the process and we have laid out
very clearly what occurred uh and uh
again don't want to get ahead of this
the Department of Justice you you all
can uh will will get your your questions
answered from them during the during
this uh during this time and so I would
just refer you to the Department of
Justice and now as you all know there's
a special counsel here thank you Karine
another one on garage gate
what is the White House trying to hide
nothing
someone gave the president a statement
to read on Tuesday that was incomplete
at best misleading at worst
who
so I have read out the president's
statement I've read it out yesterday and
what he said
he said that he will he respects or he
takes classified information and
documents very seriously that's what he
said he said that he did not know that
the records were there he does not know
what's in them he said that you heard
from him directly on this and his team
has been cooperating fully fully and not
only that again I'll say this the
attorney general said this himself that
he heard from the team shortly after so
we have laid out laid out uh what has
occurred here you've heard from the
White House Council I just read the
statement from from his lawyer and again
uh you know we take this very seriously
and the president does as well when will
the White House release a log of
visitors to the Wilmington House you
know
um Peter you've asked this question or
is your colleagues I've asked this
question before let's not forget uh what
we did here in this white house we
instituted something that the last
Administration got rid of which is
putting out the white house uh putting
making sure that there was a White House
law extensive White House log so the
American people got to see the house
again
unsecured classified material again I
I'm telling you we did something that
the last Administration got rid of which
is instituting the White House logs uh
did you ask the last Administration why
they got rid of the White House laws
okay let's go let's go well did Fox did
go ahead go ahead thank you go ahead
the Delaware residents oh I'm sorry I
was calling the gentleman who wanted to
ask a question that was not related to
this yeah that's great I appreciate it I
know I'm a little behind the news cycle
here but I want to go back to
yesterday's op-ed from the president on
big Tech regulation
um
in Washington state we've got uh the
chairs of both Senate and House Commerce
committees and uh congresswoman Morris
Rogers put out a statement saying
essentially great I let's do it let's
put forward this uh bill that passed per
committee almost unanimously last
Congress the data privacy protection act
just want to know if the president
supports and the White House supports
that bill so the president has long
called for uh strong privacy protection
so that is something that he's been
doing and calling for uh since almost
the beginning of his administration we
are heartened to see bipartisan uh
cooperation continue on this important
issue on this critical issue as the
president said in his Wall Street
Journal op-ed as you mentioned as you
were referring to the op-ed that that
came out recently Democrats and
Republicans need to come together to
pass serious Federal protections for
Americans privacy including the
strongest possible protections for
minors that means clear limits on how
companies can collect use and share
highly personal data we welcome to your
question we welcome the partnership of
Senator Cantwell our chairwoman McMorris
Rogers congressman pallone and others in
getting a bipartisan product to the
presidents that that's that protects our
privacy and also protects our the
privacy of our children we think this is
a critical importance issue and again
we'll continue to call for this has been
specifically the pushback from
California lawmakers worried about
preempting state laws like California
does the president believe that it's
important to have a strong like a
national standard for data privacy even
if it's weaker than individual state
laws so look I don't have uh I don't
have any uh news to make about specifics
of the pieces uh that's what the
specific pieces of the legislation I'll
just say I'll just say this we work we
look forward to working with both
parties and both houses to get privacy
and other Tech legislation done we think
again it's important for the protection
of the protection the protection of
privacy is important for Americans
across the country but also let's not
forget our children
subject okay was the Corvette searched
thank you thank you I'm sorry go ahead
no thank you I have a couple of
questions here but I wanted to follow up
quickly you have said repeatedly that
the president's lawyers did the right
thing but you also said earlier during
the briefing of the president's lawyers
immediately reaching out to the National
Archives they quote they were not
compelled to do it they did it
voluntarily is it the position of the
White House that legally uh the
president could have just held on to
these that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying they did the right thing period I
wouldn't read into it I'm saying that
they did the right thing and they did it
voluntarily because it is the right
thing to do when you find these types of
documents to indeed reach out to the
archivist and reach out to the
Department of Justice so they and and
outside of that they have been
cooperating very closely with uh
cooperating very closely with the
Department of Justice it is the and
rightfully so they did this but I guess
I'm just a little confused and I want to
move on but what did you mean when you
said that they you know we're not
compelled to do it they did it they did
it they did the right thing that's it I
wouldn't I wouldn't go into down into a
rabbit hole on this they did the right
thing by reaching out to the archivist
and to the Department of Justice the
White House know how many stops these
classified documents made before they
ended up in his home in Delaware or in
the fighting pen office for instance can
you rule out that there was a third stop
between a secure location and the garage
again I would refer you to Department of
Justice
there was a question that was asked
about the visitor blogs with regards to
folks who have come in and out of the
president's home in Delaware does the
administration have any idea between the
garage and the Biden pen office
um just how many people could have
gotten their hands on this or you know
or we'd assume that the White House
doesn't have an estimate there's an
ongoing review on this and I would refer
to the Department of Justice okay and
then
you know just finally
um the president has said that his
lawyers have advised him not to ask what
was in these classified documents I
don't understand the purpose of that
he's the president United States
because we're trying to do this by the
book we're trying to do this uh in in
the appropriate way uh and so that's
what I would say to you we have we have
his team has been uh complying right uh
cooperating uh with uh with the
Department of Justice and I will leave
it there I'm not going to go beyond the
book says that he can't look at this
what would compel him or push him in
that direction because you've said it
repeatedly what I guess as he tries to
do this by the book as he tries to do
the right thing you know what are his
lawyers looking at that says yeah don't
look at this classified information that
was found again there's a process here
the process is that when the lawyers
found that these documents existed they
reached out to the archive and also the
Department of Justice that is the
process and they have been they have
been cooperating uh closely working
closely with the Department of justice
and now as you've heard the attorney
general made a statement today and so I
would refer you to them all right
everybody thank you oh go ahead Steve
twice in the last six months the FBI has
had to visit the home private home of a
current and a former president to
collect classified material does the
federal government have records
retention problem that needs to be
addressed look I'm not going to get into
the politics of this or the specifics of
this all I can say is the president has
been very clear on this he takes this
very seriously again he was surprised
that the records were there that the
documents were there he does not know
what's in them his team did the right
thing right which is as the moment that
they realized the documents were there
they reached out to the archive and they
reach out to the doj I will see you all
tomorrow thank you everybody